the future of space exploration in large
part rests in this man's hands
NASA Administrator Jim Bryden Stein as
the world remembers the moon landings he
is focused on the future and the Artemis
mission a deliberately ambitious plan to
put American astronauts back on the moon
in 2024 we've tried to go to the moon
over and over again in American history
since the Apollo era and it always fails
the question is why it fails not because
of the technical risk it fails because
of the political risk so when a program
goes 15 years then you have
administration's change or congresses
change budgets change priorities change
you never get to the end state and so
what what the president has said is that
we're gonna accelerate the path so we're
gonna go within five years go and get it
done we retire the political risk by
accelerating this time though the crew
will look a bit different you spoke
about how the ambition is to put the
first woman on the moon yes will that
woman be the first of her crew to step
out onto the surface I would imagine
that the next person we have walking on
the moon will be a woman who ever goes
they'll be working in a new way NASA is
partnering closely with private industry
heralding a new space economy built on
mining tourism and research have you
considered that actually you might be
paving the way for humans to make the
same mistake in space when it comes to
mining and so on as they have done on
earth so I mean I think when it comes to
the resources of the moon that's
ultimately what will drive commercial
industry and development of space it's
what drove people to come to the United
States of America and then expand West
and ultimately that will drive the
expansion of humanity into our own solar
system so now I don't see that as being
counterproductive I see it as being very
productive but it's it's absolutely true
that there's a regulatory piece to this
that has not yet been developed that we
need to make sure we get right that
expansion is fraught with geopolitical
risk government and commercial
satellites are already targets for
hacking and the US Russia China and
India have all successfully demonstrated
the ability to shoot satellites out of
space as a result bridenstine fully
backs Donald Trump's plan to create a
military space force and I'll tell you
why it's becoming more and more
dangerous and there are people around
the world countries around the world
that believe that they're gonna get an
advantage by destroying space but people
need to know this you will not get an
advantage over the United States by
destroying space what you will do is you
will destroy space and to the extent
that we have a space force it is it is
to make sure if we can convince people
properly and rightly that they can't get
an advantage by destroying space then
they won't make those investments that's
the goal so that space can be preserved
for humanity for science for exploration
for Commerce that's the goal and then
NASA wants to use its more permanent
presence on the moon to send people to
Mars there are complex organic compounds
on Mars the building blocks for life
exist on Mars they don't exist on the
moon they exist on Mars doesn't mean
that there was life there I don't know
neither does anybody else but we ought
to go find out I think there could come
a day when we find life on another world
and when that happens I think it should
be done by the United States of America
leading a coalition of free nations and
and that's ultimately what we're trying
to achieve navigating the path to our
future in space full of possibilities
competition and risk
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News at the NASA
headquarters in Washington DC